بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
يقول
الحافظ النووي رحمه الله في رياضه في باب
الاخلاص واحضار النيه وعن ابي هريره رضي
الله عنه
قال قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلاه الرجل في جماعه تزيد على صلاته في
سوقه وبيته بضعا 20 درجه وذلك ان احدهم
اذا توضا فاحسن الوضوء ثم اتى المسجد لا
يريد الا الصلاه لا ينهزه الا الصلاه لم
يخطو خطوه الا رفع له بها درجه وحط عنه
بها خطيئه حتى يدخل المسجد فاذا دخل
المسجد كان في الصلاه ما كانت الصلاه هي
تحبسه والملائكه يصلون على احدكم ما دام
في مجلسه الذي صلى فيه يقولون اللهم ارحمه
اللهم اغفر له اللهم تب عليه ما لم يؤذي
فيه ما لم يحدث فيه متفق عليه وهذا لفظ
مسلم وقوله صلى الله عليه وسلم ينهزه
هو بفتح الياء والهاء وبالزاي اي يخرجه
وينهضه
ابي هريره رضي الله عنه
الله صلى الله عليه
‏ine
over pray in mar home meaning alone
or as some scholars have stated alone or
in jah
by 20 some
levels
‏And that is that when one of them when
a man makes
and perfects his w how does a person
perfect his
right it's it's something you have
or you don't how do you perfect it? It's
kind of how
oftentimes in people's minds
‏F
you are f
and
perfect
الاحسان
لغه العرب
هولاتقان
ذلك ان احدهم اذا توضا فاحسن الوضوء يعني
اتقنه
صنع الله الذي اتقن كل شيء
الذي احسن كل شيء خلقه
ف
اتقان الوضوء ان يتوضا
الوضوء التام الكامل
ويتم وضوءه
على نهج محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم وعلى صفه
وضوئه
make
accordance of the prop
anday
to
و
all
ثم اتى المسجد لا يريد الا الصلاه هنا
النيه وهذا الشاهد من الحديث
ذكر النووي رحمه الله هذا الحديث في باب
الاخلاص واحضار النيه
هنا الشاهد من الحديث ثم اتى المسجد لا
يريد الا الصلاه لا ينهزه
يعني يحركه وينهضه
الى الا الصلاه
وضو
‏head
and the only thing he desires at the is
prayer
only moving him to the and
trip to the
prayer
لم يخ
رفع
وحط عنه بها خطيئه
مسند الامام احمد لم ثم
ذهب الى المسجد
كان
رجله اليمنى
كلما خطا بها خطوه الى المسجد رفع له بها
درجه واليسرى كلما خطا بها خطوه الى
المسجد وضعت عنه
بها خطيئه
وعلى كل
ال اللفظ هنا في هذا الحديث عام
والحديث الاخر ان صح لفظه فهو لا يتناقض
مع هذا فهما مجتمعان على الاقل
صلى الله عليه
‏will
takنا
فهمنا المقصود
بصلاه الرجل في جماعه في جماعه لانه
الانسان ممكن يفهم من هذا في جماعه لو صلى
الجماعه في حي الله مكانه لو صلى الجماعه
في بيته لو صلى الجماعه في سوقه
لا يشترط الذهاب الى المسجد هنا جاء تفسير
هذا يقول
ثم اتى المسجد
وقال حتى يدخل المسجد
فالمسجد جد له هذا الفضل العظيم على سائر
الجماعات
فالانسان لو صلى في جماعه في غير المسجد
لم يحظو بهذا الاجر العظيم لان المسجد له
خاصه لان المسجد بيت من بيوت الله تعالى
ولان المسجد له احكام
خاصه
تخصه
جماعه
[Silence]
anyما
‏met areas
people
not
make together
those of
انء اللهم
[Silence]
امام
الشافعي رحمه الله الرساله
قال انه لا يرى الجماعه
في المسجد بعد الجماعه الاولى مع الامام
وقال تصح صلاتهم مع الكراهيه
ايه تصح صلاتهم مع الكراهيه
ايها الشافعي يا ابا
يا ايها الشافعي يقول رحمه الله تعالى
يقول
بانه لا يحبه ولا يفضله
وتصح مع الكراهيه مع الكراهه
والا فالسنه الا تصلى جماعه في المسجد بعد
الجماعه الاولى وقال تس تصح صلاته
مع الكراهه لان السلف السلف يعني الصحابه
لان الصحابه لم يفعلوا ذلك هكذا قال
ساد رحمه الله تعالى بوك الامجماعه
[Silence]
‏in
wouldce
but
the discouraged he said because
did not to do
انس بن مالك رضي الله عنه
صلاه الجماعه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏So for instance مسود رضي الله عنه came
to the masjid
with his students from his home. His
students used to meet him at his home.
Used to teach them come to the and as
they were approaching the people leaving
the
leaving the
go back home. عن س بن مسعود رضي الله عنه
جماعه رضي الله عنه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
makeلا
with
‏You guys know the narration he was in
the narration is in was
and
after they finished the prayer man
walked in pray by himself
prop
said to the companion من يصلي مع هذا
فيتصدق
‏willay
and
make
ابو
رضي الله عنه
person isn't thisidence
yes this isided
by maority of the schar
however
رحمه الله
madeصلاه
someone
made
other
question and this
الشافعي رحمه الله تعالى
على كل حال
marعه
beج
in firstماج
‏mares
[Silence]
مسجد طريق مسجد الطريق ومساجد الطرق
مؤذن
ace
on
you know
countes et you pass by these
‏mar
some
طريق
this kind of have
any
to be مسجد طريجماعه
[Silence]
time
ان شاء الله والله اعلم الله وسلم على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
والحمد لله رب العالمين وجزاكم الله خيرا
يلا